[Music]
today's question comes from amai in new
jersey my husband and i have paid off
our credit card debt and have 31 000 in
car loans left to pay off i'm thinking
about selling my dream car in order to
be debt free i owe seventeen thousand
and the car is worth thirty thousand we
have two other vehicles a beater that my
husband can continue to drive and a 2014
f-150 that i would drive i think i could
sell my car for about 27 000 and use the
10 000 profit towards the 14 000 truck
loan we're currently renting and this
step could get us closer to buying a
home please tell us if this is a good
idea as this is a very emotional
decision for me
oh man it's a lot of numbers so 31 000
and carlin left to pay off she get 10k
profit she sold the car
so she'd be down yeah to 21. so i'm
seeing here they have three cars
currently yes and one
truck has a 14k loan the dream car has a
17k loan but that 17k loan she could
sell that same car for 27 to 30 000
making a nice profit right now so i'm a
big for sure yes
now the emotion i think is coming out of
this is my dream car anyone anytime i
see the word dream i think wow it's the
only one in existence the only one ever
that will ever be built in the history
of this world whether it's a car or a
home
yeah the dream
that word it
it holds a lot of emotion and sometimes
not the wisest financial decision that's
true because of what we believe in that
it becomes very singular focus that this
is it and you can make really bad
decisions never be able to buy this car
again never it's true george so well
it's not true rachel
i was i was being sarcastic so yes am i
i would sell that dream car i would use
the profit towards the 14k loan you're
spot-on because this is gonna cut your
your debt-free journey in half
yeah which means so oh gosh so fast so
fast
sacrifice for another and you got three
cars so you're gonna be okay it is
amazing though when when you go on this
journey to change your mindset around
money because
what am i in is a very normal situation
right thirty one thousand dollars in car
loans uh they had credit card debt
they've already paid off but i'm like
it's
that lifestyle the credit card debt the
car alone even throwing a student loan
just for fun
that is the normal mindset in america
today when it comes to money and so
shifting that
mindset flipping it on its head and say
okay what if it looked like if i didn't
use credit cards and i paid off my debt
what if i actually drove a car that i
could pay cash for
which may mean me selling my current car
you know or aggressively paying it off
you know it makes the whole decisions
when it comes to money
it changes everything it changes the way
you look at this stuff and part of that
is
selling
things to be able to get you ahead and
thinking about opportunity cost if i
drive my dream car it means we can't be
in that house that we want to buy which
she mentioned for another five years but
if we sold the car we got a debt faster
we could start saving up for the down
payment faster we could get in that
house in three years and so then you
start to go what's more important to me
what do i value more looking fancy in a
depreciating asset or being in a home
because we've been renting for our whole
life yep and we want to be at home you
make different decisions when you look
at yeah through that lens that and
that's the importance too of having long
term and short term goals though to say
hey what do we want to do because if if
if you weren't thinking about buying a
house then you'd probably just be doing
what you've been doing today but for for
my it's like okay i could what i want in
the future here in the next few years i
can make sacrifices today to get what i
really want that actually would be a
smart decision financially that dream it
always changes three years from now
you'll have a different dream absolutely